les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mâcon au
prêt à des jeunes via twitter instagram
pickton est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant en poule et où ça n'a
plus rien c'est pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
il pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique dont il se désintéresserait
en lieu et place de politiser les jeunes
ça dépolitise la politique pendant la
rendant encore plus quand on est
justement c'est une nouvelle forme de
communication assez verticale utiliser
des influenceurs pour moissac hommes
politiques personnelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme si son travail en notre nom
pour nous aider dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
nouveauté depuis cette semaine vos
réactions sur télégramme les télégrammes
de rt france vous pourrez prendre part
au débat donner notre opinion et
interpeller nos invités au sommaire de
ce jeudi 14 octobre une compass
résidentiel qui ne dit pas son nom entre
des candidats plus que pressenti mais
non déclarés et des partis qui cherchent
toujours leur tête d'affiche emmanuel
macron est omniprésent sur le terrain
médiatique et même sur les terrains de
foot eric zemmour non déclarés lui non
plus devient de plus en plus gênant pour
marine le pen qui lui tend la main ou
encore les républicains qui doivent
choisir entre six prétendants et vous et
vous arrivez vous à y voir clair dans
tout ça qu'en pensez vous présidentielle
2022 est ce le grand bazar pour vous
pouvez réagir donc sur notre compte et
les grammaires t france
le liban at il atteint un point de
non-retour une mobilisation organisée
par le res bola a tourné au drame ces
dernières heures on compte au moins six
morts et une trentaine de blessés et
violences qui ont éclaté lors d'une
mobilisation contre le vu chargé de
l'enquêté sur l'explosion du port les
quartiers de beyrouth transformée en
véritable scène de guerre des chars de
l'armée ont été déployés dans la
capitale
la france appelle de son côté à
l'apaisement
comment faire plier londres et obtenir
davantage de licences pour les pêcheurs
français la france sort la carte de
l'ultimatum aujourd'hui elle donne une
semaine au royaume uni pour accorder des
sésames supplémentaires aux français
pour accéder aux eaux britanniques
poissonneuses parmi les mesures de
rétorsion brandie par paris la réduction
des livraisons d'électricité à jersey un
bras de fer complexe contentera de vous
expliquer à 21h
[Musique]
emmanuel macron qui chausse ses crampons
dans les yvelines et en seine saint
denis pour séduire les jeunes un
déplacement présidentiel allures de
campagne électorale sans être déclarés
candidats pendant ce temps marine le pen
fait du pied à l'hypothèse eric zemmour
enfin du côté des républicains on
cherche encore le leader pour la course
à la présidentielle multiplication des
annonces chocs et des déplacements qui
porte à croire que la campagne a déjà
démarré avec solène beaudet
emmanuel macron sur le terrain le chef
de l'état était en seine saint denis ce
jeudi où il a rencontré des jeunes
sportifs pour parler de l'organisation
des jeux olympiques en france mais avant
2024 il semblerait que le locataire de
l'élysée vise 2022 s'il ne s'est pas
encore déclaré candidat à la prochaine
présidentielle
ses dernières interventions 1 sonne
comme une entrée dans la compétition un
écran géant caméra 200 invités
l'annoncent ce mardi du plan
d'investissement baptisé france 2030
havel allures d'un meeting électoral
celui d'une campagne qui ne dit pas
encore son nom emmanuel macron 1 le
favori dans les sondages des enquêtes
dont les scénarios pour le second tour
sont suspendus depuis l'un des semaines
à une autre candidature potentielle
celle d'eric zemmour qui semble lui
aussi mené une campagne à visage masqué
depuis quelques semaines le journaliste
et essayiste enchaîne les conférences la
promotion de son dernier ouvrage les
débats télévisés
ou encore les rencontres avec le
patronat un agenda qui laisse de moins
en moins planer le doute sur ses
intentions celle des électeurs en tout
cas le place au coude à coude avec
marine le pen à ce stade seulement trois
points les séparent
alors qu'eric zemmour entretient le
suspense la présidente du rassemblement
national lui tend la main nous serons
amenés à un moment donné ou un autre
affaire le rassemblement je ne souhaite
pas que la candidature d'eric zemmour
soit uniquement une division en réalité
de notre capacité à gagner cette
élection présidentielle selon le même
sondage si eric zemmour se déclarait
candidat il attirerait un quart des
électeurs des républicains
la droite doit élire son candidat le 4
décembre prochain mais sans attendre les
républicains se sont lancé
officiellement dans la course à l'elysée
ce mercredi par un communiqué publié sur
twitter une entrée en campagne certes
mais qui démarre son tête d'affiche des
candidats à la présidentielle qui
maintiennent donc le suspense le parti
des républicains suspendu au vote du
congrès pour départager six candidats
est ce le grand bazar pour 2022 à ce
stade en tout cas c'est la question que
l'on vous pose ce soir en étant toujours
aux réactions sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france et c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage
avec nous pour en parler ce soir arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire bonsoir un os
benedetti merci d'être avec nous alexis
poulain vos côtés éditorialiste
politique on dirait que tous les deux ce
soir mot tout d'abord sur les images de
cette fin d'après midi on va pas vous
dévoile alexis est déjà en train de jeu
je me sens jubilé alexis emmanuel macron
qui qui voit la short tee-shirt un petit
peu trop grand quand même crampons qui
joue au foot pour la bonne cause c'est
en tout cas officiellement ce qu'on nous
dit un coup de com un petit peu décalé
plus sérieusement par rapport aux
préoccupations des des français alexis
blanc oui complètement enfin jeu on a
toujours hurler président qui joue au
foot comme ça on a eu giscard d'estaing
évidemment françois hollande le faisait
mais il faut voir le contexte je crois
que là il ya une telle désinvolture dans
la pratique du pouvoir des manuels
macron un tel mépris finalement des
français qui souffrent de manière
perpétuelle que avoir des images de ce
président qui s'amuse de cette façon là
pour beaucoup de français je pense c'est
1 1 une souffrance un coup de couteau
s'est pas nécessaire on attend du
président alors que l'inflation est
partout alors que la crise du coc vide
n'est pas terminé alors que l'on ne sait
pas comment on va sortir d'une crise
économique qui
seront pas là on a perdu un petit peu à
l'exception d'un oui mais voilà on vous
a récupéré alexis un petit point de lyon
espèrent en car nos aînés si nous
entendons aussi parce que manifestement
voilà or on vous l'a dit poursuivre
alexis oui désolé donc il ya quelque
chose de l'ordre de l'indécence bien sûr
dans je ne les empêche pas l un conte de
s'amuser évidemment mais d'amener les
caméras alors qu'il est en campagne sans
le dire que chaque jour il a une annonce
pour marseille pour les chasseurs pour
les professeurs enfin bref et il était
jeudi start peur internationale en train
de présenter le plan france 2030 chaque
jour en fait il met un nouveau costume
on sait qu emmanuel macron adore se
déguiser là il se déguise en
footballeurs pour la bonne cause nous
dit on mais la bonne cause est ce que ce
serait pas à un moment d'arrêter de
demander aux français de rentrer dans ce
délire autoritaire dupas sanitaire
perpétuelle d'avoir aussi des démos
ration ou même une politique réelle par
rapport à l'augmentation du prix du
carburant et du prix des énergies
beaucoup de français aujourd'hui se
demandent comment ils vont chauffer cet
hiver aucune réponse réelle à part un
chèque énergie mais qui ne suffira sans
doute pas donc on a l'impression qu'il
gouverne sans gouverner qui lie à une
désinvolture terrible et je crois que
ces images elles sont à contre-pied de
la communication des wagons qui veut se
rendre cool auprès des publics les plus
jeunes on se rappelle de might like
carlito ses nombreuses vidéos sur tik
tok et instagram mais là honnêtement
c'est pas ni le lieu ni le moment de
faire ce genre d'exercice a nommé des
métiers vous le spécialiste de la
communication dans le même temps il est
évidemment urgent pour emmanuel macron
de se rapprocher de cette jeunesse qui
se laissent souvent tenté par les
sirènes de la droite dure n'est ce pas
c'est vrai que emmanuel macron une
relation avec les jeunes qui y est
complexe c'est à dire que quand on
regarde des études d'opinion notamment
chez les 18 24 ans ils bénéficient d'un
capital qu'on le veuille lourde de
sympathie lors ça ne veut pas dire que
ce capital de sympathie ce capital de
confiance se constituer un capital
électoral d'abord fondé t-il encore que
les jeunes alimenter ce qui aujourd'hui
ne paraît pas la chose du monde la mieux
partagée chez eux mais la réalité c'est
qu'il est dans une communication qu'est
une communication qui vise à occuper
tout l'espace médiatique au moment où la
plupart de ses concurrents et ben sont
en difficulté manifestement à gauche où
on voit bien qu'il n'ya aucune
aujourd'hui candidature naturelle qui
semble s'imposer à droite on voit les
républicains qui ne sont pas sortis
encore de la question du mode de
désignation de leur leader et du côté du
rassemblement national des difficultés à
imposer marine le pen alors que la
candidature d'eads exe vous ressemble
jour après jour rendre une partie de cet
électorat dont il bénéficie de fait
friture helmand presque d'une scène
politique qui parce qu elle est éclatée
lui est favorable donc emmanuel macron
vous savez c'est quelqu'un qui sait
quand il est temps quand il apparaît
qu'en quantum il a parlé du sourire
notamment sur le plan de l'opinion
publique c'est quelqu'un qui relâche
sans communication et là on est
véritablement avec une communication qui
n'a rien d'innovant que comme le
rappelle très justement alexis poule à
il faut se souvenir des images au début
des années 2000 de valéry giscard
d'estaing en short en cas de jouer au
football ou de jouer de l'accordéon sur
ixen nobert dieuze et une communication
qui de fait est une communication très
ancienne la communication utilisés
emmanuel macron alors il se saisit du
football pourquoi il se dissout pas
parce que le football c'est fédérateur
dont ils pensent que ce capital
fédérateur il va pouvoir investir et en
faire une ressource politique mais c'est
vrai que il ya quand même quelque chose
d'assez décalé d'aviron pris feu d'une
situation est compliquée qu'il est
compliqué quand même sur le plan
sanitaire avec la question du pass
sanitaires dont on comprend qu'il va
être prorogée au delà de la date
où on voit que la question de l'énergie
et du coup des nervis va se poser pour
les ménages les plus modestes et même
pour les français qui disposent d'un
certain nombre de ressources
il essaye surtout injuste un dernier
point il essaye surtout d'avoir un
discours tourné vers l'avenir alors
pourquoi tourner vers l'avenir parce que
tout simplement son mandat a été percuté
par deux crises majeures une crise
sociale qui est la crise des gilet jaune
et la crise sanitaire qui l'a quand même
beaucoup handicapé dans dans sa volonté
de développer son son logiciel les cours
mixtes alors vous vous parlé tous les
deux évidemment la crise de nerf et du
pouvoir d'achat m'enfin entre deux 2
passes de foot et un penalty précisément
transformer emmanuel macron a quand même
parlé les prix du gaz et d'essence je
propose de l'écouter sur cette
proposition qui est l'étude
donc il ya un une action que nous menons
sur le plan diplomatique et
internationales pour essayer de deux des
contre un de ces prix de il ya une
action de court terme qui est en effet
d'accompagnement des ménages et le
gouvernement il travaille il y aura dans
les prochains jours a complété sa
réponse en fonction de l'évolution pour
ne laisser personne dans le dans le
désarroi évidemment lexique poulain
emmanuel macron pas du pain on a vu
émerger des petites mobilisation en
province des appels a réitéré la crise
et des gilet jaune avec cette question
du pouvoir d'achat et il a conscience
évidemment emmanuel macron qui joue gros
sur cette question
oui il joue au parce que le prix de
l'essence est aujourd'hui plus élevé que
lorsque
non plus
l ex il faut là qu'on est un petit peu
perdues à l'aube et des teams même
question c'est vrai qu'il va falloir
sans lampard et rapidement pour le chef
d'état pas encore officiellement en
campagne mais tout de même ça va être
l'un des points clés de cette campagne
on le voit déjà
si vous voulez il ya le fond on est
quand même de la crise des gilet jaune
qui continuent à peser sur ce
quinquennat il faut se souvenir que
cette crise sociale majeure et est parti
la question de la taxe et l'augmentation
de la taxe carbone donc emmanuel macron
sait très bien que le pays est un pays
qui reste fondamentalement éruptif et
que les problèmes que posent élégie les
gens n'ont pas été réglé loin s'en faut
par son mandat ce qui est quand même
très étonnant de l'entendre s'est
longtemps parlé de la de l'action
diplomatique kim est allé je trouve
qu'il ya quand même un langlement
aujourd'hui notamment dont beaucoup
d'analysés mais parfois chez nombre de
ses opposants c'est que aujourd'hui la
france sur la scène internationale et
particulièrement isolé quand on regarde
g m le bilan diplomatique d' emmanuel
macron c'est un bilan qui pose un
certain nombre de questions on voit que
la relation avec les états unis malgré
deux jambes à edel est une relation pour
le moins quand même ambivalente la crise
des sous marins australiens l'a rappelé
avec force on voit que la volonté d'
emmanuel macron d'imposer le thème de la
souveraineté partagée des loin c'est le
moins qu'on pût par d'être partagé par
l'ensemble de nos partenaires
européen donc on est quand même dans une
situation qui à la fois sur le plan
intérieur et sur le plan extérieur
permettrait à des opposants ont organisé
de pouvoir quand même faire valoir un
certain nombre de jeux les dires de
dysfonctionnements dans le bilan des
manuels dans le bilan des vacances mais
encore une fois encore une fois la
balkanisation du champ politique
aujourd'hui tels que les voix de
l'opposition ont beaucoup de mal d'où
qu'elles viennent d'ailleurs à se faire
entendre si ce n'est peut-être est
peut-être celle au long du déroulement
alors marine le pen en tout cas étaient
aussi en déplacement justement on va en
parler d'eric zemmour parce que marine
le pen était en déplacement de campagne
sur le thème elle aussi du pouvoir
d'achat elle a proposé la baisse de tva
sur le fuel et surtout elle s'est
adressée à eric zemmour qui lui fait
beaucoup de tort effectivement dans les
sondages avec cette petite phrase écouté
il serait mieux qu'il n'y ait qu'un seul
candidat mais pour l'instant eric n'est
pas prêt à entendre
alexis pour l'heure on sent qu'elle est
en difficulté petit appel du pied quand
même à cherche à faire alliance
alors aller où je sais pas mais elle
cherche au moins à clarifier les choses
elle a déjà demandé à ce que eric
zemmour se porte candidat officiellement
pour clarifier les choses et est
clairement elle a beaucoup à y perdre
eric zemmour il est là évidemment pour
finir le travail enigma kron avait
éclaté la gauche en étant sortis de la
cuisse du ps pour créer la pluie quand
marché puis au fur et à mesure il est
devenu un président de centre droit et
il est maintenant la droite udf le
centre tel qu'il est il n'ya pas il n'a
pas d'élu gauche à la république en
marche même s'il y en a qui pensent
qu'ils sont encore la gauche et donc
eric zemmour lui pousse les l'air à une
clarification politique et pousse
évidemment marine le pen à une sorte de
ringardisation c'est à dire qu'eric
zemmour c'est le coucou qui fait son nid
là où le demi a été fait par la famille
de peine moi je ne m'appelle pas le
plein moi je peux dire des choses que
marine le pen n'aurait jamais pu dire de
son temps politique et je récupère
finalement tout le travail qui a été
fait par et le père et la fille le pen
il ya quelque chose d'assez tragique il
ya quelque chose d'assez injuste pour de
voir ce coup pour récupérer tout ce
travail de longue haleine de son père et
d'elle-même et je comprends ses appels
du pied
la façon qu'elle a d'essayer de
clarifier les choses et c'est vrai que
vit on a un champ politique ouvert où
tout est possible la candidature d'eric
zemmour n'est qu'un premier
première surprise de cette campagne il
n'y aura sans doute beaucoup d'autres
parce que le bilan des manuels macron il
ne veut pas en parler parce que au-delà
de la crise sanitaire c'est un bilan
catastrophique
l'histoire se rappellera de ce
quinquennat simplement les gilets jaunes
en dix ans il y a eu un mouvement social
majeur qui a été réprimée dans le sang
et une entourloupe médiatique c'était le
grand débat et regarder la communication
des mâles de la crise c'est quoi c'est
se mettre au centre et parler monopolisé
la parole refaire le coup du grand débat
et ce qui est inquiétant c'est que la
france va être présidente de la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne dès janvier et 150 millions
d'euros sont provisionnés pour cette
présidence est évidemment qu emmanuel
macron utilisera cette présidence pour
faire campagne et là encore une fois
rappelez vous lors des européennes il
avait utilisé le grand débat pour faire
campagne donc le jeu est totalement faux
c'est le jeu démocratique est totalement
faux c'est à la fois sur les candidats
qui ont du mal à se financer si on parle
de marine le pen voyez le nombre de
banques qui lui ferme la porte au nez
qui refuse de lui faire des prêts dans
quelle démocratie sommes-nous alors que
pour une manade mac pour son parti qui
n'existe quasiment pas la république en
marche un trésor de guerre parce que de
nombreux élus est en train d'organiser
une campagne avec cette fameuse maison
commune qui est simplement art packaging
un rebranding comme on dit dans le
marketing politique pour changer de nom
et refaire l'entourloupe 2010 est donc
aujourd'hui s'il faut mettre en avant
ses lacunes du jeu démocratique et
politique c'est et le financement et le
temps médiatique de chacun de ces
candidats sachant que le président
sortant a quand même attendent avance et
devrait être critiqué pour ça je
voudrais qu'on s'arrête quelques
instants sur ces réactions insolente
compte instagram d'ayrté france
notamment celle ci qui vient de tomber
grand bazar où grande mascarade après
avoir agité durant des années
l'épouvantail un de la famille le pen
nous voilà qu'on nous présente désormais
l'épouvantail 2.0 plus terrifiant plus
extrêmes monsieur zemmour qui n'est même
pas encore déclaré candidat arnaud
benedetti c un épouvantail où un
candidat qu'il faut prendre très au
sérieux et l'eczéma moore selon vont
alors ciblé il ya un paradoxe a vécu
l'exil où je partage totalement ce que
lier avec s'il voulait c'est que eric
zemmour en effet aujourd'hui il est en
train de vampiriser une partie de
l'électorat du rassemblement national et
il est aussi en train de vampiriser une
partie de l'électorat des républicains
je rappelle donc que dans le premier
sondage harris qui le place en tête
devant marine le pen 24% des électeurs
de françois fillon de 2017 disent être
prêts à voter pour
eric zemmour eric zemmour ce qui est
très surprenant c'est que il est
fondamentalement est profondément plus
clivants que marine le pen qui de ce
point de vue là quand même largement
aplani son discours et tient un discours
alors avec lequel on ne peut ne pas être
d'accord mais le qui est un discours
finalement qui est assez peu clients sur
le fond ce et le constat c'est que eric
zemmour tout temps clivante peut-être
beaucoup plus que marié le pen à une
assiette politique qui parlait beaucoup
plus large
donc ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez surprenant parce qu ils pensent
ils voulaient des deux côtés des droits
il prend bien évidemment sur le
rassemblement national mais il prend
aussi on le voit bien chez les
républicains comme si l'exil bourg était
plus présentable que marine le pen
l'autre aspect qui sera décisif pour
cette élection présidentielle et dont
finalement très peu de monde parle c'est
de savoir si les classes populaires vont
retourner aux urnes si les classes
populaires où elle tourne aux urnes le
scénario qu'on nous présente aujourd'hui
peut en effet être profondément modifiée
et aujourd'hui même emmanuel macron
compte pas se nourrit de deux choses qui
se nourrit en effet de la dispersion des
oppositions politiques saluent profite
et de et deuxièmement de la désaffection
civique ou de la désaffection électorale
d'une partie de nos compatriotes
en effet si le il ya un moment donné une
offre politique qui arrive être un
projet et si les classes populaires et
les classes moyennes retournent aux
urnes les choses peuvent évoluer et
changer effectivement nommés des récits
vous nous parler des républicains
d'ailleurs il en a conscience eric
zemmour il dit tout simplement c'est ce
matin chez nos confères de ces news je
fernet le fpr et edouard philippe fait
renaître l'udf
lr n'a plus de raison d'être c'est
clairement une opération de destruction
qu'il mène à droite avant justement de
s'attaquer aussi à marine le pen avec
six points ce sera le mot de la fin oui
complètement il est là pour changer
l'échiquier politique pour clarifier les
choses parce que c'est sûr que les
républicains sont la fin de commettre de
l'ump et vous avez des gens dans ce
parti qui n'ont plus rien à faire
ensemble que ce soit eric ciotti qui dit
voter pour eric zemmour et le maire de
nice christian estrosi qui lui est
officiellement macro nist donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué de tenir une
stratégie une synthèse donc la synthèse
a vécu et là on a effectivement une
clarification à droite qui sert emmanuel
macron au final parce que un gros pôle
de droite avec un candidat qui serait le
rpr évidemment une droite plus dur une
droite plus idéologique que ce centre
créé par emmanuel macron pourrait être
un candidat qui ferait peur emmanuel
macron mais là aujourd'hui comme on est
dans le temps de la restructuration il
n'y aura pas le temps de la campagne et
lui emmanuel macron qu'est ce qu'il fait
eh bien il est tous les jours sur le
terrain tous les jours en campagne sans
le dire avec l'argent public bien sûr
avec ce stature présidentielle qui fait
que dès qu'ils parlent les médias
tendent le pot donc on est dans un jeu
totalement faussée et pour la droite
c'est extrêmement compliqué parce que le
temps de la reconstruction il est
pendant la campagne et il n'est pas été
fait en amont donc c'est trop tard ça
veut dire que peu importe quel candidat
sortira du congrès dlr il sera handicapé
et peu importe si eric zemmour est
candidat ou non le mal est fait donc on
a on va se retrouver avec des camps
politiques car un cas qui vont essayer
de faire quelque chose regarder à gauche
anne hidalgo ce n'est pas mieux ce soir
le parti socialiste lui donne une
investiture de paille pour dire qu'il
faut faire une campagne qui n'existe pas
donc on est là dans une campagne qui
n'existe pas une drôle de campagne comme
il ya eu la drôle de guerre et quand la
campagne va commencer quand on aura des
candidats officiels alors là sans doute
les choses ont changé mais aujourd'hui
c'est totalement au bénéfice des malades
merci beaucoup à tous les deux arnaud
benedetti avec six poulains merci à vous
et l'un des sujets de grogne sociale
dont emmanuel macron devra certainement
répondre s'il fait ou quand il fera
plutôt officiellement campagne la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et cette
nouvelle salle de négociations
aujourd'hui entre l'exécutif et les
syndicats réunis devant le conseil
d'état à paris depuis le 1er octobre une
nouvelle règle est appliquée pour
calculer le montant de l'allocation et
syndicats espèrent obtenir une
suspension de cette dernière les
explications des stèles farges
le conseil d'état va t'il a décidé comme
en juin dernier de suspendre les
nouvelles règles de calcul du salaire
journalier de référence celui qui sert à
calculer les allocations chômage les
syndicats en tout cas eux elle l'espère
objectif de l'audience de ce jeudi donc
pour les syndicats plaidé en faveur
d'une suspension mais aussi est dénoncé
un passage en force du gouvernement
s'est en tout cas est ce qu a indiqué
l'avocat de la cgt à nos confrères de la
fp selon lui l'exécutif n'avait a pas le
droit de publier un nouveau décret
autant que la décision du conseil d'état
du mois de juin était toujours en
vigueur et je vous propose d'écouter à
ce propos le responsable emploi chômage
de la cgt mais pour l'instant on ne peut
pas retenir grand-chose de l'audience de
pour savoir dans quel sens ça va pencher
tout le monde a développé ses arguments
on a été face aux fables du gouvernement
mais les fables et sont multiples un le
bc les allocations des chômeurs ça va
léser permettre de retrouver du travail
plus facilement c'est une réforme
équilibrée entre le bonus malus qui
s'appliquent aux entreprises et les
baisses des allocations pour les
chômeurs
et le contexte économique est fabuleux
tout est revenu à la normale comme avant
le coc vide bon la réalité sur tous ces
points là on a évidemment contester la
question car le 30 septembre dernier
l'exécutif a publié un décret pour
appliquer cette nouvelle règle de calcul
le coeur de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage dès le 1er octobre sans
attendent donc le jugement sur le fond
du conseil d'état je vous rappelle que
l'instance avait été saisi en juin par
les syndicats qui avait donc obtenu la
suspension de cette nouvelle règle de
calcul le conseil d'état avait hâte à
leur estime et sans remettre en cause
dans le principe de la réforme qu'être
des incertitudes demeuraient sur la
situation économique du pays et que et
bien ces incertitudes ne permettait pas
la mise en place de cette règle de
calcul est celle ci pénalisant notamment
les salariés ayant alterné contrats
courts et inactivité la décision du
conseil d'état donc sur cette nouvelle
demande de suspension devrait intervenir
ces prochains jours une nouvelle
audience sur le fond est aussi attendu
mais d'ici quelques semaines
elle la france et les etats unis
appellent à l'apaisement au liban on
assister aujourd'hui à de véritables
scènes de guerre en plein coeur de la
capitale une mobilisation à l'appel du
hezbollah qui a tourné au drame on
compte au moins six morts et une
trentaine de blessés par balles une
manifestation contre le juge tarek ebit
à are en charge de l'enquêté sur
l'explosion du port leucate ou 2020
objectif pour le mouvement chiite faire
pression et intimidé le magistrat alors
que l'enquêté piétine depuis plus d'un
an le gouvernement redoute une escalade
de la violence en soit xavier lambert
[Musique]
la guerre à nouveau en plein coeur de
beyrouth
l'armée libanaise mitraillent la façade
d'un immeuble ou serez positionné des
tireurs embusqués plusieurs sniper
viennent d'ouvrir le feu sur une
manifestation organisée par des
mouvements chiites
sous les tirs des habitants sont évacués
par les secouristes derrière les
véhicules blindés et des chars qui
boucle tous les accès au quartier
après plusieurs heures des changes de
feu nourri les militaires libanais
reprennent finalement le contrôle les
premiers bilans font état de six morts
et d'une trentaine de blessés
le crime a été d'utiliser des armes pour
tuer des gens c'est le problème
principal et cela n'a rien à voir avec
la manifestation
cette manifestation pacifique a été
préalablement organisée par des avocats
et des élites qui ont une certaine
demande en lien avec la politique ou une
autre question que vous connaissez tous
ce rassemblement était organisé à
l'appel de deux organisations sheets le
puissant hezbollah et son allié le
mouvement amal les deux partis accusent
les milices chrétiennes des forces
libanaises d'avoir mené ces attaques des
accusations démenties par ces milices
dès ce matin des centaines de partisans
chiites s'étaient réunis devant le
palais de justice pour exiger le
remplacement du juge chargé de l'enquêté
sur l'explosion du port de beyrouth
tarek bitar qu'ils accusent de mener une
enquête partiale soul influence des
occidentaux il ya eu de nombreuses
erreurs qui ont été commises par ce
nouvel enquêteur qui doivent être
réexaminées afin qu'ils travaillent pour
établir la vérité est que les familles
des victimes ne devienne pas elles mêmes
des victimes
depuis plusieurs semaines la pression
est de plus en plus forte sur le
magistrat qui tente d'auditionner
d'anciens ministres chiites parmi eux
plusieurs ont saisi la justice pour
suspendre l'enquète notamment ali hassan
khalil et ghazi zeaiter dont les
plaintes ont été rejetées ce matin par
la cour de cassation l'enquète va donc
se poursuivre pour mettre en lumière les
responsables de l'explosion qui a tué
plus de 200 personnes le 4 août 2020 une
tragédie qui aurait été provoqué par le
stockage sans surveillance d'énormes
quantités de nitrate
moniotte pointé du doigt pour négligence
criminelle les autorités libanaises ont
toujours refusé la mise en place d'une
enquête internationale
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois al-bacha économise fondateur de
libnanews
bonsoir mâcha merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rtl france
comment expliquez vous cette nouvelle
flambée de violence après cette
manifestation organisée par le hesbollah
mansour et jaillissent c'était un peu un
scénario qui était déjà écrit dès hier
soir on s'attendait à ce type de
violence
on avait des informations qu'elle est
dans ce sens qu on avait les propos de
l'ancien ministre
des finances ali hassan khalil déjà qui
faisait part de problèmes liés à la
stabilité du liban en cas de mise en
examen les actes de landas d'arrêt à son
encontre donc c'était un scénario déjà
déjà écrit il suffisait de mettre un peu
d'huile sur le feu
on a vu cette couverture médiatique
plutôt occidental évidemment les laisser
penser que le hezbollah aujourd'hui
était responsable des tirs mais aimer
sur le terrain est ce que c'est vraiment
le cas
c'est confus d'ivoire c'est très confus
il ya des témoignages qui indique qu'une
personne aurait d'abord tiré et tué sept
personnes étaient présentes au sein des
manifestants et ça va prêter entre dione
le signal pour l'embrasement qui a eu
lieu il ya d'autres sources qui accusait
source ibanez et d'autres ressources qui
a vécu des manifestants c'est encore
très confus ce qu'on sait pour le moment
c'est qu'il ya neuf personnes qui ont
été arrêtées par l'armée libanaise dont
un ressortissant syrien qui serait l'un
des concierge de l'immeuble où se
seraient positionnés les snipers
aujourd'hui pourquoi ça 7
misson pressions de la part du us vole à
7000 suppressions en même temps du
mouvement amal intervient alors que
depuis le début de semaine il y a eu une
crise politique majeure au sein du
gouvernement n'y a t'il avec la menace
même de démissionner du gouvernement en
cas de poursuite de l' enquête
oui je vous en prie faisant qu'on pense
ce qu'il veut donc l enquête est gênant
pour certains est certain et c'est tout
de même de faire dessaisir le jugement
le juge très glitter comme de mentionner
dans votre reportage
alors aujourd'hui la france marc savi
préoccupations et appelle à l'apaisement
réitère la nécessité pour la justice
libanaise aussi de pouvoir travailler de
manière indépendante et impartiale ce
n'est pas le cas actuellement
le dossier du port de beyrouth est un
dossier hautement politique l'explosion
du port de beyrouth est une chose et le
port lui-même était un une plateforme de
contrebande est une plateforme de
caisses noires pour les différents
partis politiques et le ministère des
finances en cela comme en sa qualité de
tutelle le ministère de tutelle des
douanes était fortement impliqué là
dedans ce qui implique également que le
mini d'anciens ministres des finances à
deir ezzor à lille connaît beaucoup de
choses s'il n'en a pas synap a également
participé à cela
en tout cas nous mêmes oui il m'a
lui-même évoqué qui avait 5 milliards de
dollars qui disparaissaient chaque année
du port de beyrouth
en 2015 ou 2016 donc
même si on met à part l'histoire de
l'explosion du port de meilleur beyrouth
qui est qui et quand même majeurs il y a
une grande perte pour l'état le revenu
et cela également participé à la crise
économique à l'explosion de social et
économique qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui clairement que peut faire le
gouvernement
de najib mikati pour apaiser les
tensions commencent se sortir de cette
crise
le gouvernement nagib mikati a passé son
état de grâce après cette constitution
il est coincé le s'il
persiste s'ils ne désirent pas à la
sphère du port de beyrouth à un autre
juge
les ministres sunnites et chiites pardon
menacent de démissionner ce qui mettra
fin techniquement peut-être à son
existence parce que en plus il est
rejoint par un ministre marada
s'il décide de poursuivre l' enquête
donc ce scénario si et répondre ainsi
et répondront aussi aussi à l'exigence
de la communauté internationale dans le
cadre de la transparence et de la
réforme du système judiciaire nécessaire
aussi dans la lutte contre la corruption
il pourrait obtenir l'aide économique et
ainsi un peu sauvé l'économie mais il
n'existerait plus s'il choisit enfin de
d'arrêter d'arrêter les frais et de
dessaisir le juge ça serait un très
mauvais signe pour la communauté
internationale et pour l'obtention de
l'aide économique donc c'est un c'est un
gouvernement aujourd'hui en suspens
merci beaucoup françois el bacha d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
et dans l'actualité également les
politiques en tunisie plus de deux mois
après son coup de force au président
qu'à essaye de n'est plus seul à la tête
de l'exécutif
nommé le 11 octobre jeu-là bouden
première femme chef du gouvernement du
monde arabe a présenté sa nouvelle
équipe de 25 ministres dont le fameux
chargée de lutter contre la corruption
de restaurer la confiance en l'état
alors que le pays vit toujours sous les
mesures exceptionnelles renforcée par
décret présidentiel le 22 septembre la
classe politique tunisienne toujours
privé de participation aussi entre
compréhension et colère mais c'est mme
chénier avec hey there nasri
au quartier général du parti et ayari
charbit il règne comme un calme
inhabituel depuis le coup de force du
président sayed le 25 juillet dernier
malgré le gel de l'activité du parlement
et l'interruption de la participation
des parties politique quand j'arrive
nationale certaines formations
reconnaissent la nécessité d'un
changement en profondeur du système
politique tunisien un changement qui
leur semblent être incarnée par l'homme
fort de la tunisie kaïs sayed le parti
taillard chaâbi et rassuré par ce
gouvernement d'après 25 juillet
plusieurs raisons ce gouvernement je lui
soutient du peuple tunisien
contrairement à ceux d'après 2011 qui
étaient pour la plupart issus de complot
et d'arrangements politiques
depuis il pas des moindres c'est une
femme qui est à la tête de ce nouveau
gouvernement
une première dans le monde arabe sans
parler du fait qu'une grande partie sont
des femmes
je pense que cette nuit du 25 juillet
kaïs sayed nous a remis sur les rails de
la démocratie une démocratie ne devrait
pas avoir de parti politique qui se font
les porte paroles du terrorisme où des
puissances étrangères
heureuse de voir une femme à la tête du
gouvernement ou apte à bellaïd reste
prudente membre du bureau exécutif du
parti d'affi atone elle attend des actes
forts de la part du président de la
république a commencé par une
clarification de sa feuille de route et
un retour au dialogue avec les partis
politiques
seule condition selon elle au maintien
des acquis démocratiques de la
dévolution de 2011 le parti a donné sa
écueils et bien sûr avec satisfaction la
nomination du gouvernement tout en
sachant que depuis le 25 juillet nous
étions sans gouvernement et avaient
aussi la suspension du parlement c'est
une revendication de la classe politique
ce gouvernement est caractérisée par la
nomination d'une femme chef de
gouvernement c'est une première en
tunisie nous sommes très fiers de cette
nomination aux partenariats et aux noces
du gouvernement nous devons le soutenir
parce que c'est là peut-être la dernière
chance et un gouvernement qui va nous
permettre de passer de cette période
transitoire vers une nouvelle
les autres plus stable avec la reprise
du fonctionnement des différentes
institutions de l'état nous attendons
dans ce cadre que le président de la
république nous précise le la durée de
ces mesures exceptionnelles qui ont été
prises donc on vend dix corps et nous
demandons au président de la république
de de faire participer les uns des
différents intervenants à ceux à ce
dialogue disons ou à ce nouveau système
politique comme d'autres membres de
l'opposition le parti ai'a démocratique
dénonce la nomination d'un gouvernement
aux prérogatives réduites mise en place
pour servir le projet d'un seul homme au
détriment de réelle orientation et d'un
programme au service du pays puis le 25
juillet ce qui caractérise la politique
du président kaïs saïed c'est de sortir
progressivement de la constitution avec
comprend culminant évidemment le 22
septembre et sa décision de suspendre la
constitution et de la remplacer par une
organisation provisoire des pouvoirs il
ne peut pas prétendre les lui
qui compte par ailleurs amender la
constitution
de son propre chef mi à mener une
réforme politique de grande envergure
sans dialogues sont en discussions avec
les parties prenantes je ne m'attends
honnêtement pas à ce qu'un gouvernement
qui ait choisi de travailler
souvent pire de la décision du 22
septembre pour voir
restaurer les quelques acquis de la
démocratie qui ont été vraiment violé
ces derniers temps il ya aussi une autre
première à noter c'est que c'est la
première chef du gouvernement en tunisie
à
noeuds ça mais à ne jamais s'exprimer
qui a été on va dire spolié de sa voix
mais qui a été aussi spolié de ses
pouvoirs qui sont inscrits dans la
constitution donc c'est bien d'eux
d'avoir nommé une femme chef du
gouvernement on aurait aimé que ce soit
dans de meilleures circonstances et que
l est les mêmes prérogatives que ses
prédécesseurs
don à la casbah et qu'elle est surtout
une voix et une politique une vision
pour la tunisie ce que visiblement elle
n'a pas encore réussi à nous transmettre
dans une tunisie fragilisé criblé de
dettes émises à terre par des années de
mauvaise gestion k et saez ne semble
toujours pas prêt à accorder sa
confiance à une classe politique qui
considèrent comme profondément corrompu
malgré la nomination d'un gouvernement
que réclamait l'opposition et la
puissante centrale syndicale ugtt était
le président de la république demeure à
ce jour en vertu des mesures
exceptionnelles le réel détenteur du
pouvoir exécutif dans le pays
les états unis démentent sont
normalisation avec la syrie de bachar
el-assad petite mise au point hier
pendant la rencontre et partick israël
usa émirats arabes unis à washington une
réponse aux critiques croissantes contre
le silence américain qui reviendrait
pour beaucoup d'observateurs a accepté
tacitement une organisation on en parle
avec un autre correspondant à washington
thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas la question
sienne s'est invitée ce n'était pourtant
pas à l'ordre du jour
non ce n'était pas l'objet principal des
discussions tripartites entre les
etats-unis israël et les émirats arabes
unis mais il faut dire que les positions
de ces trois pays divergent sur le
dossier syrien parce que par exemple les
autorités emirati ont annoncé dimanche
dernier un plan le lancement d'un plan
pour renforcer la coopération économique
avec la syrie une énième illustration de
la normalisation en cours entre des
relations entre damas et des pays de la
région anthony blinken a donc été
interrogé sur ce dossier syrien il a
tenu donc à rappeler le positionnement
américain écouter
ce que nous n'avons pas fait et que nous
n'entendons pas faire c'est exprimer un
quelconque soutien aux efforts en vue
d'une normalisation des relations ont
une réhabilitation de monsieur assad ou
lever la moindre sanction contre la
civic ou changer notre position pour
nous opposer à la reconstruction de la
syrie tant qu'il n'y aura pas de progrès
vers cible vers une solution politique
ce qui selon nous est nécessaire et
vitale
voilà pour la position ferme de
washington mais force est de constater
que ce processus de normalisation des
relations entre damas et les pays de la
région suit son cours il ya l'exemple de
la jordanie qui a rouvert récemment son
principal poste frontière avec la syrie
il ya même eu un échange téléphonique
entre le roi abdallah ii et le président
syrien bachar al assad s'était le
premier échange entre les deux hommes
depuis dix ans et ce changement
d'attitude vis-à-vis de damas et
documentée dans une enquête publiée par
newsweek qui consacre la une de sa
dernière édition au président syrien
avec ce titre il est de retour et il
parle même du triomphe du président
syrien sur les états unis alors
l'actualité a en effet montré une
certaine passivité des etats-unis
vis-à-vis de ces rapprochements entre
damas et différents acteurs régionaux
mais une conseillère de bachar al assad
qui est cité dans cet article tempère un
petit peu ce triomphalisme en expliquant
que tant qu'il y aura des troupes
étrangères qui sont présentes
illégalement sur le territoire syrien et
bien il n'y aura pas de victoire il
convient en effet de rappeler que malgré
les appels de joe biden à mettre un
terme à ces guerres interminables au
moyen-orient il y à l'heure actuelle
encore environ 900 soldats américains
qui stationnent en syrie merci thomas
bonnin en direct de washington et pour
approfondir le sujet nous sommes avec
régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france qui a d'ailleurs écrit un livre
justement sur bachar el-assad qui l'a
interviewé bonsoir régis merci d'être
avec nous agen al assad en couverture du
newsweek sais c'est pas forcément
courant on en reparle washington dément
toute normalisation il n'empêche il
semble revenir au centre du jeu le
président syrien pour quelles raisons
alors il semble revenir au centre du jeu
ça fait déjà un petit moment parler des
émirats des émirats aurait ouvert leur
ambassade il ya deux ans et donc
il y a eu
plusieurs appels la jordanie évidemment
a commencé à retraités avec avec le
gouvernement assad également le liban
aussi qui est en crise mais quand même
il ya eu des des parlementaires libanais
qui se sont rendus en syrie c'était la
première fois depuis dix ans et
progressivement en fait la raison
principale c'est que on sent bien que
beaucoup de pays arabes fonctionne de
façon assez pragmatique et dans la crise
syrienne ils
se rendent compte qu'il ya un état de
fait c'est la victoire de bachar al
assad c'est à dire que on peut comment
critiquer l'homme on peut critiquer sa
position peut critiquer tout ce qu'il a
fait la réalité c'est que il y a dix ans
il avait quasiment perdu le contrôle des
deux tiers de son territoire et
qu'aujourd'hui il en est il à avoir
conquis environ 85 % il reste les kurdes
vous avez mentionné votre correspondant
aux états unis a mentionné la présence
des américains 900 américains mais en
réalité il reste la zone dite libre donc
au nord-ouest qui compte toujours
contrôlé par l'opposition et c'est
principalement par le groupe j ai dit ça
ya thaï rath cham et que en dehors de ça
il a reconquis le pays donc il ya une
sorte de d'état de fait qui fait que
beaucoup pays arabes se disent vu la
position centrale de la syrie au
moyen-orient on le voit très bien d'un
point de vue économique également
puisque il ya un plan justement
d'acheminer vers le liban des
hydrocarbures égyptien et de
l'électricité jordanienne et ce plan-là
prévoit que ça passe par la syrie c'est
un plan qui a eu l'approbation tacite
des états unis alors aujourd'hui il ya
une sorte d'emballement mais à partir du
moment où la diplomatie américaine dit
nous ne traitons pas avec bachar al
assad nous n'allons pas vers une
normalisation de nos relations avec la
syrie ça veut dire quand même qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe et puis
l'autre tu as tu fait c'est qu'on a on a
oublié enfin on l'a pas oublié mais le
fait que les américains aujourd'hui
traite avec les talibans on se dit
pourquoi neutre être est il pas
également en tous cas n'aurait habits
reptiles pas des relations avec le
gouvernement assad lac et la question
elle est aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
veut faire
moyen-orient qu'est-ce que comment on
veut que cette zone finalement
arrivèrent vers une normalisation en
tout cas une pacification justement
régit cette victoire des talibans le
fait qu'on traite avec eux ça veut dire
que maintenant les amis américains
parlent avec des gens qu'ils estimé
auparavant
infréquentable c'est
cette étape qu'on vient de franchir
justement je pense que dans le mouvement
qui entre 1 à 2 de caumont de provoquer
de qui sont en train de provoquer des
etats-unis dans le monde engrais
réajustant leurs politiques
internationales il ya un constat de
réalisme il ya un constat d'intérêt
américains on l'a vu avec la faire des
sous marins on l'a vu avec eux un
certain nombre avec le retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui les américains ont
des priorités et que les priorités
évidemment ce ne sont plus le
moyen-orient ni résistante râle c'est la
chine et donc il ya une oeuvre eu un
amant une amorce d'une
d'un changement majeur dans la politique
étrangère américaine et face à ça
évidemment les états unis ont finalement
provoqué le retour des talibans au
pouvoir faut rappeler quand même que les
talibans en termes de crime c'est le
groupe djihadiste le plus criminel des
dix dernières années donc
donc c'est on discute avec des gens
aujourd'hui à doha qui ont qui ont passé
leur vie dans la clandestinité qu'on
perpétrer des attentats je vais pas
citer les noms blémant du gouvernement
mais y en a un certain nombre qui sont
impliqués dans des actes
comment pour lesquelles les américains
les avait d'une certaine façon désignée
comme terroriste est aujourd'hui donc
les américains des ide dialogue avec des
gens qui considéré autrefois comme des
terroristes donc ce réalisme cette prise
en compte aussi de l'émergence d'autres
d'autres puissances le vide près créée
par les américains par leur retrait en
partiel d'irak et total d'afghanistan et
bien fait que des puissances local
régional et maire je pense en
particulier à la turquie mais également
à l'iran qui revient aussi dans l'est
dans le jeu des négociations et tout ça
c'est que la politique américaine
aujourd'hui elle est beaucoup plus
pragmatique et donc
sur la une sur le volet syrien il ya
aussi une interrogation comment voilà on
peut pas traiter les problèmes du liban
si on ne traite pas les problèmes de la
syrie est aujourd'hui il y a plus
d'acteurs donc les états unis prend
prennent une certaine façon comment
conscience qu' il y à d'autres acteurs
et que eux ne sont plus dans le jeu ça
veut dire en gros le retour du réalisme
après des décennies de messianisme
démocratique s'est terminée ça alors
tout à fait on sait que mais c'est
terminé s'est pas terminée et que
gouvernement by donne ça l'était déjà
avec le gouvernement tron je rappelle
que trump malgré tout sa rhétorique
enflammée n'a jamais déclenché une
guerre c'est un des rares présidents
américains ne pas l'avoir fait barack
obama lui avant était déjà sur cette
ligne ne faut jamais oublier que barack
obama est un président président
américain qui a été élu sur une ligne
anti guerre par rapport à son
prédécesseur george bush et donc que ce
mouvement il a commencé d'ailleurs le
mouvement de retrait d'afghanistan et de
retrait d'irak 1 on l'a oublié mais 2010
c'est sous barack obama que les troupes
américaines sont revenus un peu de façon
un peu précipité puisque du coup des ch
a émergé juste après mais on peut dire
ce mouvement américain se replie
américains vers ses propres intérêts que
donald trump à a synthétisé dans la
formule america first et bien il est
déjà été
commencées dans les législatures
précédentes donc maintenant on en voit
aussi beaucoup de conséquences on est
arrivé au terme de l'engagement
américain en afghanistan avec la
conséquence qui est le retour des
taliban maintenant eux il est probable
également que les américains ne
resteront pas des années en syrie et en
irak pour la bonne et simple raison
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'ont plus grand
chose à y faire merci vous courage et le
sommier grand reporter tesfran semble
pour votre analyse ce soir merci
et un mot de cette attaque à l'arc en
norvège hier soir un homme armé d'un arc
et de flèches a tué au moins cinq
personnes et compte berre et près d'oslo
et deux autres personnes dont un
policier sont hospitalisés en soins
critiques ce soir à mémorial en hommage
aux victimes a rassemblé des dizaines
d'habitants de la ville plus de détails
avec médiers ce caissier sébastien sapa
les enquêteurs norvégiens sont toujours
à pied d'oeuvre à 15 berg au lendemain
d'une attaque meurtrière perpétrée par
un homme armé d'un arc et de flèches
cinq personnes ont été tuées et deux
autres blessées l'auteur présumé un
danois de 37 ans résidant en norvège a
reconnu les faits lors de son
interrogatoire cette nuit et était connu
de la police pour des soupçons de
radicalisation
nous parlons d'un converti à l'islam
nous sommes raisonnablement convaincu
que l'auteur a agi seul nous n'avons
aucune information indiquant autre chose
mais nous poursuivons les investigations
pour en être totalement sûr
c'est comme je lai déjà mentionné nous
enquêtons pour déterminer s'il s'agit
d'un acte de terrorisme mais cela
prendra probablement un certain temps
avant de pouvoir l'établir c'est une
évaluation quelque peu compliquée liés
aux motifs
les deux blessés ont été hospitalisés en
soins critiques sans que leur vie ne
soit pour autant en danger l'un d'entre
eux est un policier qui n'était pas en
service alors que les enquêteurs
poursuivi les interrogatoires
le nouveau premier ministre norvégien
qui a pris ses fonctions au lendemain de
l'attaqué s'est exprimé sur le drame
aujourd'hui mes premières pensées vont à
koeberg et aux personnes touchées qui
s'y trouvent celles qui ont perdu la vie
celles qui ont été blessés celles qui
vivent sur le choc de cet acte
monstrueux qui a marqué cette belle
ville
c'est un contexte lourd mais néanmoins
aujourd'hui est le jour de la
présentation du nouveau gouvernement
l'équipe que j'ai derrière moi est une
équipe dont je suis très fier en
laquelle j'ai confiance pour participer
au changement de la norvège et mettre
notre pays sur une nouvelle voie pour
les habitants de cette petite ville
tranquille de kohlberg c'est
l'incompréhension les quelques vingt
mille habitants forme d'une communauté
resserré
yann le voisin de l'auteur présumé de
l'attaqué l'a aperçu le jour du drame
c'est une personne assez grande avec des
cheveux courts son visage était toujours
inquiet
non pas inquiet
sérieux il était sérieux
pas de sourire
rien sur le visage
il regardait juste avec un air pas très
amical
il avait l'air un peu en colère
et je le voyais toujours seul
le pays a été la cible d'attaqués au
cours des dernières années en juillet
2011 anders breivik avait fait exploser
une bombe aux abords des locaux du
gouvernement à oslo puis avait commis le
massacre de l'île d'utoya tuant au total
77 personnes en août 2019 un homme avait
tiré sur une mosquée près de la capitale
sans faire de blessé grave
regarde tensions entre la serbie et le
kosovo également dans l'actualité
internationale des affrontements ont
opposé hier des civils fermé des
policiers kosovars à l'origine de ces
violences une opération des forces de
l'ordre contre les produits de
contrebande plusieurs personnes ont été
blessées le chef de la diplomatie
européenne appel local juliette a mis
ce mercredi lors d'une réunion avec des
représentants serbes vivant près de la
région du kosovo le président de la
serbie a mis en garde les autorités
locales
à propos des récents événements d'autres
et pour le bus ou comment la mode https
si nous devons commencer le combat afin
de protéger la vie de nos enfants et
leur survie au kosovo metohija non
seulement nous protégeons nos enfants
mais je vous promets pour la première
fois que nous allons gagner ce combat à
coup sûr leur mascotte pour pari foot
des déclarations qui font suite à un
regain de tension dans cette province
sensible mercredi matin de violents
affrontements ont eu lieu entre
policiers kosovars et civils serbes à
mitrovica dans le nord de la région des
véhicules blindés ont rapidement été
déployés pour ramener le calme dans la
ville d'après les forces de l'ordre huit
personnes ont été arrêtées selon les
autorités locales cette flambée de
violence survient après des raids menés
par la police kosovare pour saisir des
biens de contrebande détenus par des
serbes juste après ces affrontements le
gouvernement serbe a appelé ses
concitoyens à ne pas céder à la
provocation
je demande à nouveau à notre courageux
peuple serbe de rester calme et
pacifique et de ne pas céder aux
provocations de la plus haute importance
et signification car avec ces actions
insensée du psychopathe albine curti
prix ce qui l'a peut provoquer une crise
aux conséquences bien plus importantes
des accusations auxquelles l'exécutif
local a répliqué selon albine curti
premier ministre du kosovo ces
opérations policières ne vise qu'à
lutter contre la criminalité
l'intervention policière d'aujourd'hui
est terminée j'appelle les citoyens de
la partie nord de la municipalité de
mitrovica à ne pas devenir la proie des
médias serbes qui défendent la
criminalité la corruption et la
contrebande et veulent dépolitiser les
ethniciser les tensions ont été ravivées
il ya deux semaines dans la région du
kosovo après la décision de pristina
d'interdire les plaques
d'immatriculation serbes dans la
province une mesure de réciprocité selon
les autorités locales
car les véhicules immatriculés au kosovo
ne sont pas reconnue par belgrade un
conflit qui inquiète l'union européenne
qui a notamment supervisé en accord
entre les deux parties pour tenter de
résoudre la crise liée aux plaques
d'immatriculation de nouveau le chef de
la diplomatie européenne a lancé un
appel au calme les incidents violents
dans le nord du kosovo doivent cesser
immédiatement
des actions unilatérales et non
coordonnée qui mettent en danger la
stabilité sont inacceptables les
relations entre belgrade et la province
se compliquent régulièrement depuis la
déclaration d'indépendance faite par
christina en 2008 ces tensions sont
également renforcés par la situation
démographique plus de cent mille serbes
vivent actuellement dans la région du
kosovo
avec mon dans quelques instants nous
parlerons des tensions fabrique entre
londres et paris la france sort la carte
de l'ultimatum aujourd'hui elle donne
une semaine au royaume uni pour accorder
des licences supplémentaires aux
français pour accéder aux eaux
britanniques poissonneuse rester là
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts ni
sur la bbc une surprise des hopitalisés
il était nulle part est ce qu'on peut
vivre malgré cette douleur quand j'ai
écrit à la fois je souffrais parce que
ça me rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
les ong sont devenus 50 ans des acteurs
incontournables de la société moderne
par leur impact auprès des gouvernements
et du public confondant régulièrement
les grands principes avec leurs
objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations non politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le
rationnel le sectarisme de la majorité
d'entre elles des amène à des
interprétations qui exclut toute pensée
ou comportements n'allant pas dans leur
sens et leur convictions n'hésitant pas
à tordre les faits et à utiliser tous
les moyens pour imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ouverture ce 11 octobre du procès de
l'assassinât de thomas sankara 34 ans
après les faits est ce que c'est un
soulagement ça fait quand même 25 ans
que notre campagne essayent d'obtenir la
vérité la justice dans cette affaire
thomas sankara est considéré comme le
che guevara africain a été tué à 37 ans
à l'époque nous nous étions en lutte
pour obtenir la justice contre un état
partie là c'est maintenant l'état qui
est celui-là faire donc on voit déjà
qu'il ya un grand progrès j'espère que
nous allons avoir un jugement se
rappeler qu'on va aller petit à petit
vers l'élaboration vérité nous avons la
conviction que c'est quelque chose qui
est loin d'être petit complot local
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui a une
dimension internationale
mais nous ce qui nous intéresse qu' il
n'y ait plus ce cycle d'impunité qui
perdure
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire comment faire si l'on réfléchir
davantage le licences pour les pêcheurs
français la france sort la carte de
l'ultimatum aujourd'hui elle donne une
semaine au moyeu unis pour accorder des
sésames supplémentaires aux français
pour accéder aux eaux britanniques
poissonneuses parmi les mesures de
rétorsion brandie par paris la réduction
des livraisons d'électricité à jersey
est le bras de fer entre paris et l'on
continue donc à l'origine de cette
brouille post break site le nombre de
licences accordées aux pêcheurs français
11 capitales européennes dont paris ont
signé ce lundi une déclaration un texte
dans lequel lieux critique la gestion de
ce dossier par le royaume uni d'un éco
pression un ultimatum de la france lancé
à londres pour débloquer d'autres
licences de pêche y est mais la bnda
un énième ultimatum au royaume uni le
ton est donné par le secrétaire d'état
français aux affaires européennes
clément boon qui rappelle aux autorités
britanniques le délai imparti avant que
des mesures de rétorsion soit exécutée
dans le cas où le gouvernement de boris
johnson ne règlerait pas la question des
licences de pêche nous en sommes venus
avec la ministre de la mer à la
conclusion clair aujourd'hui que les
britanniques ne veulent pas donner un
certain nombre de licences non pas parce
qu'il manque d'information mais parce
qu'ils ont fait ce choix politique c'est
ici dans un délai de quinze jours qui a
déjà commencé il ya une semaine dont
10,6 à peu près huit jours que nous
annoncerons des mesures de réponse
les mesures de répliques de rétorsion le
cas échéant nationales ou européennes si
nous n'avons pas de signaux britannique
concrets de mouvement sur cette question
des licences qui n'a que trop duré
couper l'alimentation électrique des
îles anglo-normandes fut une des menaces
lancées par le gouvernement français il
y a quelques jours elle a fait très vite
réagir les autorités britanniques
cette menace de couper l'électricité
disproportionnée serait en violation du
traité commercial et serait inacceptable
cela reviendrait à couper la fourniture
d'énergie à 108 mille îliens à notre
hôpital et à nos écoles à ce jour seules
200 licences sur les 244 réclamés ont
été accordés à la france paris accuse le
royaume uni de ne pas respecter les
accords post punk sites signés à la fin
de l'année dernière ceux ci prévoient
que les pêcheurs européens puissent
continuer à travailler dans certaines
eaux britanniques à condition d'obtenir
une licence accordée s'ils peuvent
prouver qu'ils pêchaient là auparavant
ce dernier point rend la tâche difficile
les deux pays ne sont pas d'accord sur
la nature et le nombre de justificatifs
à fournir un pêcheur français va plus
loin et accusent le gouvernement
britannique de lui avoir réduit sa zone
de pêche en contradiction avec la
licence qu'ils détenaient on amènera
cette partie là
les jambes
les parloirs des parties
j'espère que là
hélas
leur zonage elle arrête aussi
voilà donc plus en plus loin des années
l'accord post briques site a été conclu
pour encadrer les échanges et les
relations entre l'union européenne et le
royaume uni durant une période
d'ajustement qui s'étend jusqu'en 2026
durant les prochaines années les quotas
de pêche des marins de l'union
européenne dans les eaux britanniques
seront réduits de 15 % la première année
et de 2,5 points de pourcentage
supplémentaires chaque année par la
suite l'accord détaille également la
répartition pour chaque espèce de
poisson entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne
l'activité halieutique des européens
dans les eaux britanniques vite une
mutation accélérée
alors que faut-il penser de cet
ultimatum de paris qui brandit la menace
de restriction des livraisons
d'électricité est ce un dernier geste de
désespoir les autorités britanniques
pour est un cd accordé plus de licence
aux pêcheurs français c'est l'heure de
notre face à face
[Musique]
et avec nous ce soir pour en parler
bruno margolle président de la
fédération des organisations de
producteurs de la pêche artisanale qui
en duplex donc avec nous bonsoir bruno
margollé merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés en tout cas sur ce plateau avec
moi pas le thompson vice-président du
parti conservateur britannique bonsoir
paul thompson merci d'être avec nous
donc on l'a entendu un dans dans le
sujet un pari qui lança un ultimatum à
londres sur la pêche bruno margolle ça
me faire réagir selon vous le royaume
uni en tout cas c'est la bonne stratégie
vous êtes satisfait en tout cas de du
sens où vont les choses
il faut dire que dix mois après l'accord
qui avait été signé entre entre l'union
européenne et l'ol et les britanniques
il s'avère qu'il ya eu neuf mois de
travaux intensifs pour trouver pour
prouver que comment les bateaux ils
travaillaient bien dans l'est dans les
eaux britanniques sauf qu'aujourd'hui le
compte n'y est pas tout simplement le
contenir corps et bien entendu je dirai
tout simplement que c'est de la mauvaise
foi de la part des britanniques parce
que ton à honda fit enfin le maximum
pour trouver
les bateaux tout au moins les les
bateaux limiteront fait essentiellement
dans la manche pour prouver par tous les
moyens possibles de leurs de leurs
commandes hors activités dans les eaux
territoriales est aujourd'hui le seul
moyen qu'on aura maintenant
ccc la réplique tout simplement quoi
parce que il faut il faut en finir comme
ça quand vous entendez c'est de la
mauvaise foi britannique qu'est ce que
vous répondez
je pense qu'il ya une
une dimension technique et une dimension
politique
les deux
sont d'un briquet très clairement à mais
il faut essayer de les
regarder séparément
je ne pense je ne suis pas un expert de
la tâche donc jeu le précise je ne pense
pas que ce soit de la la mauvaise foi de
lui du côté britannique il ya peut-être
un problème d'une
déficience de la règle qui a été établie
veut parfois à on adopte des règles pour
gérer une situation et on se rend compte
que les règles ne fonctionne pas bien
pour telle ou telle raison est ici
d'après ce que j'ai compris à
une règle de base concerne la preuve que
tal bateau attaché depuis un certain
nombre d'années et apparemment pas
surtout pour le petit bateau son
incompréhension
il y a des éléments de preuves qui ont
été avancées mais il semble t-il il n'y
a rien qui ait vraiment
concluants
et tout simplement parce que par le
passé il n'y avait pas une besoin de
tenir un registre formel
dans une forme qui était reconnu par
tout le monde par exemple donc ça
c'est si le problème est qu'une partie
du problème se trouve là dedans et je je
je retente j'aurais tendance à dire que
il ya un problème dans la
location la définition de la règle c'est
une règle qui ne peut pas vraiment
s'appliquer
donc il faudrait revoir il faudrait leur
jeu je parle à titre personnel âgé il
faudrait revoir les règles parce que ça
ne marche pas au mieux comme auteur que
je ne pense pas que ce soit de la
mauvaise foi je pense que chacun c'est
de défendre ses intérêts je sais que
depuis
longtemps il ya eu des âmes
ddd frustration au royaume uni parce que
les pêches au britannique dupas pas
seulement de
2,2 dodgers et de 7 sur la mairie plus
au nord a estimé qu'il avait des prises
trop importante
donc il ya un autre contexte plus
historique qui joue on va redonner la
parole à bruno margollé modem adle si on
comprend bien maintenant ses zones de
pêche encore disputer
londres et jersey ont déjà accordé au
total un peu plus de 2 200 licences un
définitive aux pêcheurs français paris
ont réclamé on réclame encore de 244
c'est pas suffisant clairement
aujourd'hui on vous
les plus attractives bien entendu c'est
essentiellement les navires de moins de
12 mètres parce que au moment où la
demande des britanniques de prouver les
années de référence 2012-2016 qu'ils ont
bien fait chez ces navires là n'étaient
pas équipés et delà de la balise vms
pour pouvoir envoyer leurs positions
électroniquement donc la problématique
aller là on a retrouvé par des données
vingtaine à part des deux des données de
traces de sueur sur les ordinateurs et
tout que les bateaux ont bien ont bien
une une commande
exercice dans l'essai de l'huile
aujourd'hui sur les 175 licence qu'ils
ont été demandés dans dans les dombes
enfin dans les 6 12 milles il y en a que
75 qu'ils ont été attribués sur
l'exemple vente qu'elle est aujourd'hui
il ya une surexploitation de la d2
française
par tous ces bateaux là et on arrive à
un point de non retour parce
qu'aujourd'hui les que ce soit les
bateaux qui font les ardemment les
chalutiers ou les fileyeurs et où ils
sont ils sont point de non retour parce
qu'ils ne peuvent plus se déployer sur
tout dans le détroit du pas de calais
fin dans la manche essentiellement dans
les 6 12 mille ou auxquels ils ont
toujours travaillé la seule différence
c'est que les exigences de l'accord bon
bah on a découvert ça bien entendu au
fur et à mesure des mois les exigences
de l'accord de vente de commandes de
prouver électroniquement entre 2012 et
2016 c'est comme je vous dis les moins
de douze mètres n'avait pas l'obligation
de s'équiper de cet équipement la voile
à jouer c'est la problématique pas
clairement aujourd'hui les pêcheurs
français sont les grands perdants de ces
faits cambo post break site
rien de ce qu'on entend ce soir et la
france est bien de menaces et jersey de
coupures d'électricité finalement c'est
de bonne guerre
non je ne dirais pas que ce soit de
bonne guerre parce que
couper l'électricité serait
serait une mesure drastique
qui aurait des conséquences
graves pour tous les habitants de jersey
j'ai lu que le gouverneur ou le
responsable du jersey dit qu'ils ont une
vieux générateurs ou 10 elle qu'il
essaierait de mettre en route si jamais
ça se passait mais ce serait quand même
hélas cette raison de ce qu'ils sont des
pêcheurs français leur famille
je ne sous estime absolument pas le la
gravité de la chose pour des personnes
qui sont directement directement
concernés ce que disait monsieur rejoint
pas ce que je disais à savoir il ya un
problème avec une règle qui ne
fonctionne pas à part seulement un
comtois jeu je parle à titre personnel
je pense qu'il devrait y avoir une
discussion
calme et et de bonne foi pour
adapter la règle je disais dans le
figaro qu'il a un t shirt été citée par
le journaliste du figaro qui disait
qu'il n'a pas ces éléments de preuve
mais que les autorités
de pêche attendant le jazz et le
connaissent personnellement parce qu'il
y va depuis il était depuis 20 ans oui
ils le connaissent le savent très bien
simplement pas leur rapport indirect que
il est la ddt et est depuis très
longtemps néanmoins on lui reproche qui
n'a pas
prévu donc en nettement dans un cas
comme ça
on devrait
faire quelque chose mais ce serait
vraiment anormal que quelqu'un dans ce
cas soit refusée et donc
je voudrais évoquer la dimension
politique parce que je disais au départ
que je pense qu'il ya une dimension
politique
il y a
bien bien sûr les deux sens sont
imbriqués avec
dans la négociation du traité
les pêcheurs français ni sens sur
strictement rien mais c'est un fait que
le gouvernement français emmanuel macron
très personnellement assez mis
systématiquement en pointe par une
posture une approche très agressive
vis-à-vis du royaume-uni et sa touche
encore une fois des domaines qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec la tâche
mais qui a ont été reçus par d autres
britanniques en mettant son expression
d' hostilité générale
et je pense que
ça joue peut-être ici mains encore une
fois je pense qu'il faut ce jeu je
suppose qu'il y aura une discussion
raisonnable malgré ces tensions je ne
sais pas si cet ultimatum vraiment de
nature à aider des choses mais c'est ce
qu'il faut trouver une solution
rapidement personnellement je je je
pense que le bon sens une certaine sens
d'équité
prévaudra et qu'on trouvera adaptation
raisonnable ou aux règles le mot de la
fin pour vous bruno margollé j'aimerais
vous faire réagir
justement sur ce que disait le président
du comité régional des pêches de
normandie écouter
les pêcheurs sont instrumentalisés par
des postures politiques des deux côtés
et au bout de neuf mois il n'y a pas
d'avancée il faudrait des mesures
commerciales ou bancaire est symbolique
aussi est forte ça devrait se jouer au
niveau bilatéral entre la france et le
royaume uni
aujourd'hui et ça sera le monde a faim
renault maroc vous vous sentez vous
justement instrumentalisé comme le dit
ce confrère
audit manger quoi d'avis j'ai pas d'avis
vraiment personnelle mais je fais un
juge j'ose espérer qu'il faut le trouver
un accord
l'union européenne a mis en place va
parle déjà de mettre en place des plans
de sortie de flotte un pour aider des
bateaux à sortir moi je lui dis que
c'est pas la solution aujourd'hui on est
arrivé à
status quo on a des flottilles homogène
il faut il faut garder nos flottille
pour faire vivre nos littoraux et puis
tout simplement il faut il faut arrêter
je veux dire de jouer à la balle comme
ça et puis bon voilà je pense que il
faut maintenant aujourd'hui
est sérieux et puis dire bon allez tous
les bateaux qu'ils ont pu pêcher avant
2020 avant la fin de l'année 2020 ont eu
leur comment leur licence z
européenne ils ont bien trouvé qu'ils
étaient qui pêchait dans les eaux dans
les eaux européennes de la communauté
européenne aujourd'hui on a on a prouvé
pas je voulais dit tout à l'heure par
tous les éléments qu'on pouvait qu on
pouvait essayer de prouver par tous les
bateaux on peut plus rien donné on a
tout donné aujourd'hui on a tout donné
bateau par bateau les historiques de
pêche les historiques de par tous les
moyens complet voilà tout simplement si
tout ce que je peux vous dire non
maintenant il faut être de bonne foi et
dire oui bon ben ok comme monsieur
l'expliqué un pêcheur de garnison qu'il
a toujours pêché non à des pêcheurs
qu'ils ont des bons rapports avec un des
pêcheurs anglais et puis c'est pas pour
autant qu'ils ont leur licence
aujourd'hui c'est quand même dommage ils
ont des pêcheurs ils savent bien même
les pêcheurs anglais qui sont enfin de
chez nous ils disent oui bah oui tel
bateau tel bateau il a tu repêchés on
travaille ensemble dans les eaux
britanniques dans les 6-12 mise mais la
poisse à licence parce qu'il n'a pas pu
prouver c'est quand même lamentable
merci en tout cas tous les deux pôles
thompson l'un bruno margollé d'avoir été
avec moi en direct sur rt france ce soir
retour en france il n'y a pas de
réduction du temps de travail à l'étude
dans notre pays affirmations ce matin
d'elisabeth bornes qui s'opposent à la
proposition des 32 heures porté par la
gauche la ministre du travail qui
regrette un débat totalement décalé par
rapport à la réalité selon elle les
français travaillent moins que d'autres
pays un discours qui fait écho à celui
du président emmanuel macron mardi
dernier katia technique
c'est bien connu les français sont des
fainéants et l'oise yves t étant la mère
de tous les vices la mettrait en danger
notre modèle social pour emmanuel macron
ses concitoyens ne travaillent pas assez
il l'avait déjà dit en 2019 en clôture
du grand débat il persiste et signe ça
fait toujours plaisir quand on se
compare on nous sommes un pays qui
travaille moins que les autres en
quantité ça reste vrai et donc nous
avons une quantité de travail à louer
qui n'est pas au bon niveau à la fois
dans le cycle de vie en horaire cumulée
et au fond on a une force qui est notre
modèle social et éducatif menant à une
faiblesse c'est qu'on n'a plus le modèle
productif qui permet de le financer ah
mais alors nous n'avons pas dû lire les
mêmes chiffres officiels avec la dares
direction de l'animation de la recherche
des études et des statistiques évaluons
le temps de travail hebdomadaire des
salariés en 2018 bon les salariés
français avec 36 3 heures par semaine
travaille davantage que les danois 32 3
heures les allemands 34,8 heures les
néerlandais 29,3 heures est juste un
tout petit peu moins que leurs
homologues britanniques 36 8 heures
espagnol 36,4 heures et juste pour info
les non-salariés hexagonaux ont eux
travaillé 43 9 heures par semaine en
2020 une année chamboulée par la crise
sanitaire mais 45,3 en 2018 les chefs
d'entreprise les auto-entrepreneurs les
travailleurs indépendants se tuent bien
à la tâche alors pourquoi emmanuel
macron dit il que l'on travaille moins
en france parce qu'il ne se base que sur
le temps de travail annuel ils étaient
deux mille cinq cent cinquante heures en
2020 pour les salariés français et en
2019 juste pour les salariés à temps
complet la france de dépasser que la
suède avec d'autres chiffres fournis par
l' ocde pour l'emploi total c'est à dire
les salariés plus les non salariés en
2000 1 la france est mieux classée avec
1400 deux heures annuelles travaillé en
moyenne c'est plus que le royaume uni
avec 1367 heures l'allemagne 1332 mais
moi que la pologne 1766 ou la corée du
sud 1908 et si on comparer ce qui est
comparable en 2019 une année classique
la france est un peu mieux classé même
s'il était derrière la belgique ou
l'espagne alors pourquoi ce classement
les français par plus tôt à la retraite
selon l'allusion au cycle de vie faite
par emmanuel macron et les salariés
hexagonaux dispose aussi en moyenne de
32 jours de congé par année en incluant
les rtt contre 25 pour la moyenne
européenne ah oui en fait on travaille
de manière intensive mais on a trop de
vacances c'est bien sûr mais si on a
ajouté la statistique primordial les
pays qui travaillent le plus son volume
horaire ne sont pas du tout les plus
productifs et dans ce domaine la france
est dans le peloton de tête au niveau de
son apport au pib par heure travaillée
elle écrase littéralement ses voisins
européens
elle rapporte 70 euros de l'heure contre
66 pour l'allemagne 52 pour l'espagne
focalisé son analyse sur une statistique
unique s'avère particulièrement
fallacieux d'autant que les problèmes
majeurs sont le travail partiel non
souhaitée et la moyenne du temps de
travail rapporté au nombre des actifs en
âge de travailler qui allaitent
effectivement très faibles à cause du
nombre de chômeurs mais les français ne
sont pas à blâmer pour cela emmanuel
macron compte augmenter la durée légale
du travail et repousser l'âge de départ
à la retraite tandis que d'autres pays
sont au contraire à la semaine de quatre
jours un débat réintroduit par certains
candidats de gauche à la présidentielle
au miracle les premières
expérimentations sont très prometteuses
en islande une étude menée sur 2500
salariés du privé et 440 fonctionnaires
passés aux 35 heures je rappelle que la
moyenne du travail hebdomadaire est
supérieur en france a été un succès et
en 2019 l'entreprise microsoft est passé
à la semaine de quatre jours au japon
dans un monde où les machines laisse
qu'on peu de travail aux humains le
président compte faire trimer les
français dommage que cette volonté soit
à rebours de l'époque et des idées
novatrices
nouvelle enquête sur l'origine du virus
du communisme l'organisation mondiale de
la santé désigné une équipe pour
déterminer les causes et les provenance
exacte du coc vide les explications avec
marion caudal et juliette l'ami
la question de l'origine du coc vide dix
neuf se pose à nouveau l'om est-ce à
nommer une équipe de 26 experts pour se
pencher une fois de plus sur les causes
du coronavirus table et surtout les
annonces de propose mumble de l'om s
annoncent aujourd'hui les membres
proposés du groupe scientifique
consultatif de l' oms sur les origines
des nouveaux agents pathogènes ou sagot
les 26 experts ont été sélectionnés
parmi plus de 700 candidatures qui ont
été choisis pour leur expertise et leur
expérience de classe mondiale dans un
éventail de disciplines marine giove-b
de plus
cette nouvelle équipe est donc également
chargé d'étudier les nouveaux agents
pathogènes il s'agit des facteurs qui
peuvent engendrer une maladie chez les
animaux ou les plantes avant qu'elle
soit transmise à l'homme ces études
seront réalisées notamment afin
d'anticiper l'apparition d'éventuels
virus inconnu
ce dont nous avons besoin que ce groupe
face s'est dévaluée de toute urgence où
nous en sommes dans ce que nous savons
et ce que nous ne savons pas et ce qui
doit être fait urgemment à la suite de
la dernière mission en chine plus de 3
douzaine d'études recommandé devait être
réalisée et justement le rapport de
cette dernière mission en chine en
janvier dernier évoqua quatre hypothèses
concernant l'origine du coc vite dix
neuf mais aucune n'a été prouvée
concernant la question d'une chute
accidentelle de laboratoire elle a été
jugé extrêmement improbable
cette fois ci les scientifiques
sélectionné espère bien avancé sur le
dossier parmi eux certains avaient déjà
participé à la mission précédente un
nouveau challenge pour ces experts
c'est un défi pour l'humanité de
comprendre un virus qui a arrêté la
marche de notre monde et je demande à
chacun pays membres journalistes est
absolument tout le monde de créer un
petit espace pour que cette discussion
ait lieu parce que c'est probablement
maintenant c'est notre meilleure chance
et c'est peut-être notre dernière chance
de comprendre les origines de ce virus
de manière collégiale collective et
mutuellement responsables
après son étude le groupe scientifique
publiera une évaluation indépendante de
toutes les conclusions scientifiques et
techniques disponibles pour rappel
depuis son apparition le virus du coït
10 9 a provoqué la mort de plus de 4,8
millions de personnes à travers le monde
avant de refermer cette émission
s'intéresse un rapport d'oxfam qui
pointe l'implication des banques
l'organisation de mondiale de la santé
désigné une équipe pour donc déterminé
pardonnez-moi petit voilà petits
porteurs qui saute on parle donc
effectivement de l'oxfam et son rapport
tout de suite en images
[Musique]
m
au top
[Musique]
mais
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi rendez vous lundi dès
20h d'ici là n'oubliez pas de réagir sur
télégramme rt france en attendant mon
actualité continue toute la soirée
[Musique]